you sure you guys are okay and not taken
over by an evil entities and/or my
manipulating life-forms why do you ask I
don't know you're just not making as
many long-winded speeches as usual we're
just making sure that you don't stumble
across anything
I mean don't stumble across anything I
mean segue into another conversation
well done well let's wrap up matrix
month by taking a look at what many
consider the worst of the Matrix trilogy
Matrix Revolutions yes
you
well Matrix Reloaded has strong opening
at the box office the audience reaction
was less than thrilled
both diehard fans and common moviegoers
didn't seem too excited to see where the
story was going anymore hence very few
people saw the final installment and it
bombed at the box office I know right
hard to believe a film series would
deteriorate into explanatory dialogue
and lifeless performances after the
mountain of emotion the first film gave
us but nevertheless let's see how a
franchise that hooked in so many people
so quickly could lose them all us his
fans so let's take a look at know
something something what motivation and
emotion you too can figure out even the
most basic of human emotions by reading
this book who would need help figuring
out the most basic of human emotions and
read a book to understand yes this is
Matrix Revolutions we start right where
we left off with Tom in a coma right
next to Agent Smith impersonating and
knocked out crew member don't you know I
still have the same expression no matter
what they're told however that the
Oracle has important information for
them who are you I'm the Oracle I made a
choice and that choice cost me more than
I wanted it to one thing I've learned in
all my years is that nothing ever works
out just the way you want it to like
sometimes an actress dies in between
films and you have to Dumbledore the
shit out of it what choice to help you
to guide Neil and if you're wondering
what important words she has to share
with them apparently it's only two I
know this because if the exact same two
fucking words that everybody in this
movie is brainwashed to repeat no really
for all the rambling and long-winded
speeches count how many times they just
keep coming back to the exact same two
words
Chilly's purpose choice purpose choice
this choice purpose choice choice choice
purpose the even foursome in the
sentences no normal person would ever
use them in alright let's move
like that seriously has anyone ever used
the phrase let's move with purpose and
not gotten a wedgie in high school but
for some strange reason Tom is in a
realm apparently in-between the Machine
world and reality are you from the
matrix yes no I mean I was oh wait a
minute mobile I think just maybe an
anagram for limbo oh they're trying to
tell us that this world is clever I mean
say what you will about citizen Kane's
marriage and their visual symbolism but
growing the table further and further
apart over the years subtly suggesting
through visual means that they're
growing further and further apart from
each other have they said purpose and
choice yet both basic choice there you
go the movie fell make it for a second
I don't think God the rest of the film
isn't a straightforward and doesn't
ramble on oh yeah it does I just have
never heard the program speak of love it
is a human emotion no it is a word what
matters is the connection the word
implies can you tell me what you would
give to hold on to that connection Wow
this is about as exciting is actually
waiting at a real train stop you believe
in karma karma is a word like love a way
of saying but I am here to do yeah we're
here for a while guys I hope you're
enjoying it your programs oh yes and yet
somehow like most of the machines in
this movie I seem to have much more
emotion than any of the human characters
my wife is an interactive software
program she is highly creative what are
you doing here goodness I apologize my
wife can be very direct yes please the
more of that you're the first one to say
something that isn't 20 pages long I see
that you are in love Oh what gave it
away was the how I stare into nothing
this wood no recognizable thought
because that's kind of how I normally am
haha but a character called the Train
man comes to take them away leaving Tom
behind you're gonna stay right here in
hella Merovingian says different I don't
wanna hurt you done you're hyemi I don't
need this I made it beyond thunderdome
get on the train or you stay here with
him first Tom realizes as much energy as
he puts into it he ends up going nowhere
you can personally insert your own
obvious metaphor for the movie here but
Mina I just wanna get the fuck out of
this scene this leads us to one of
Freddy's clubs which is imagine a fetish
club you do know people wear other
clothes in the real world right
got a cutie
you must be ready to die people are
taking a slow-mo gunfight because really
I don't think the films have explored
that Avenue enough and they break inside
to see the Frenchman is the prodigal
child of it dance we only want to talk
of course you do he wants to fucking
doing this movie you must have something
I Frenchy offers to make a deal that
they hand over the eyes of the Oracle
he'll give them back Tom it seems a
perfectly fair and I need a moving deal
to me but because these films love plot
threads that don't go anywhere they say
oh that shit we're just gonna point a
gun at you I guess that works
oh darling let's not say anything in
just suck face isn't any different from
what we normally do so because you found
the first boring Oracle talk in the
boring Oracle room so not boring
here's another boring Oracle talk in the
boring Oracle room that you will
definitely find boring I think it's time
for me to know a few more things so do i
and I'm not gonna lie watching a scene
where Tom does nothing but constantly
ask questions it's like watching a
conversation in a buttons and Mindy car
- where is this going I don't know you
don't know or you won't tell me no one
can see beyond a choice they don't
understand what choice it doesn't matter
why because it wasn't time for you to
know hey power of the one extends beyond
this world why it reaches from here all
the way back to where it came from
hey you are a bastard speaking of which
after Tom Lee Smith only ends up taking
over more and more people and corners
the Oracle inner kitchen I suppose
you've been expecting me right
I hate some except maybe you knew I was
gonna do that maybe you didn't what did
you do but certain cookies need love
like everything does okay this film
might have been worth the price of
admittance just to hear Hugo Weaving say
that why cookies need love like
everything does actually I think every
Hugo Weaving movie needs that line
beneath this mask there is an idea mr.
great and cookies need love like
everything does cookies
themselves
the gap desktop you will not be our end
but his cookies need love like
everything does
coming out of him it just sounds magical
funny ends up taking over the Oracle
which leads to one of the silliest and
most famously goofy laughs in movie
history I am not entirely convinced that
they didn't replace him with a Hugo
Weaving style Muppet no really I think
he did pretty well in that crowd with
that face but Tom believes he has to go
into the heart of the machines home
world to confront them and needs to take
one of their ships to do it this is what
the Oracles told you this is asinine if
you want to kill yourself go do it but
do it without wasting one of our ships
he can take mine
Oh Christ's sake Niobe I'll pilot this
ship he can take mine after all he is
the exact reason why we're in this
god-awful predicament I think he's done
more than enough to earn our phenomenal
eNOS guy to trust but Tom and Trinities
ship has a stole the most menacing Hugo
Weaving impression known to man it might
appear that way to you but mr. Anderson
and I know that appearances can be
deceiving
that is a damn good impression but can
he fit his entire fist in his mouth well
he's laughing no Tom surrenders his gun
to save Trinity resulting in agent two
kind of Smith burning his eyes off Marco
Marco oh come on it's the law you have
to say polo but because we haven't done
the blind profit cliche yet it turns out
now he can see in flame-o vision
like I think you're gonna have to drive
it's cool I can make jokes even though I
should be in blood-curdling pain thank
God my brain is so slow I constantly
forget what's actually supposed to hurt
me hey speaking of things that are
supposed to hurt me you guys are awfully
quiet over there
oh good finally things can be less
suspicious around here did you make
things less suspicious around here yes
he is totally convinced that we haven't
been affected by you good everything is
going according to plan
silence only I may do the meme worthy
laugh sorry it's okay
you
so Zion is about to be wiped out by an
army of machines it's time to take off
our shirts for no reason and get in our
machines we stole from James Cameron's
aliens who while ironically steal it
back for an Atari I think the real
battle is between which film series is
trying to be less original
and to think this is all because our
beloved Messiah said fuck it I want to
get laid more you all could get axed off
by Cthulhu sperm well I run away taking
one of your ships that's essential to
your survival
best Messiah ever so I hope you like
people shooting upward and shouting ah
because there's exactly 20 minutes of it
you get to watch yep
20 minutes of this boat and all its
visual wonder just look at all the
palettes of color that they have on
display like gray dark gray vomit grace
not gray stone reflecting off of dim
fireplace gray and all accompanied by
flashing lights so constant that even a
rave and a haunted house would get bored
by it but Murphy's ship comes in with
for lack of a better term a friggin off
switch and finally stops the fighting
you did it
you're a hell of a pilot no we're a hell
of a pilot we really should stop this no
we really should say oh yeah sure
but it turns out much like Tom their
ability to save the day ends up instead
somehow fucking more people over
did I miss something commander I thought
we just saved the dog that EMP knocked
out almost every piece of hardware in
every APU if I were the machines I would
send every signal I had here right now
save the dock captain just handed it to
him on a silver platter but you know the
thought occurs to me we're not very good
at what we do but hey at least we
believed right no strategy no reason
just all faith believing that's that's a
good lesson to take out this right good
things for people to learn in the future
I'll just let myself meanwhile tomat
Randy continue to fly towards Skynet to
try and make a deal for the future but
they are eventually spotted after a
pretty friggin long time however Tom is
able to zap most of them with his Jesus
beans but they eventually end up
punching his spirit which means they
have to go higher up
color it's been so long since I've seen
Colin oh well back to the Willis
smoke-stained greens and urine cake
blues what a world of imagination we
live in huh the ship crashes and Trinity
it seems is somewhat inconvenient by the
results I don't think she'd be quite so
calm or coherent with those metal cord
sticking out of her body
my guess is her dialog would be a mix of
gargling blood and no really you can't
die you don't have the acting ability to
do so wait try to think of something the
Oracle said we've escaped this scenario
with bullshit loopholes before well good
to know all the lives you let die in
Zion resulted in the exact same outcome
for Trinity's dead ass but hey I'm sure
was all part of the grand plan that was
about as well planned out as the one in
signs seriously think doesn't think it's
so through
well Tom mourns the loss of his partner
in Bland's ion gets ready to face the
machines second wave attention Zaya
do not fear this is only a drill but
before they can wipe them out
Tom approaches the leader of the
machines the time baby and tries to make
a truce with them am I the only one who
wants to hear this come out of that
thing's mouth seeing how Smith has
apparently infected all of the matrix
including the machines and programs Tom
says he can get rid of him in exchange
for leaving Zion alone why they can't
just make another matrix like they've
done so many times in the past I don't
know but let's just pretend this movie
isn't very good at answering questions
and then pretend you're not pretending
the magic of tentacle hantai he's thrown
back into the matrix where Smith has
indeed taken over everything now is the
monsoon of our discontent like what I've
done with the place
so remember how crazy fun and
over-the-top that fight was in the
middle of the movies with a million
Smith's all attacking at once you might
be asking yourself how the hell are they
gonna top that well by producing it
downs it's just one of course because
yeah even though they had a brilliant
idea by having our hero fight just one
villain as well as an entire army both
at the same time and actually kind of an
ingenious set up they said hey let's
just throw in the same slow-mo kungfu
you've seen a million times mixed in
with some Dragon Ball Z action you've
seen a million times except now it's
mostly blocked by the rain so it's even
harder to make out what's going on guys
that's not upping the ante that's taking
away from the ante why don't you do that
it's so bizarre why they thought this
would equal a bigger climax than the
last fight they had with this man's hell
it doesn't even add up in the last film
he took on like a bajillion of them
fighting them off like they're deflating
balloons why the fuck now can he just do
that to one of them what's this one I'm
gonna kill you oh no I'm defeated that
was pretty easy why is he having such a
hard time with this guy
hell even the video game had a better
climax than this a giant version of
himself made out of the city okay it was
pretty fucking silly but have you come
to expect that from these films by now
at least it was something bigger and
different why are we supposed to be
impressed by this why indeed mr. al joke
really
schmuck I knew you unpacked enough -
what's going on here no it's very simple
really I just want you to finish the
review what why because then maybe pens
will at least check out the movie to see
just how bad it is yes the more you hate
it the more likely it is to gain
viewership from where it tanked at the
box office
bad shit I'm not reviewing the rest of
it then no I'm afraid you have to mr.
out critic for as you see I've grown
quite an army oh what's the plan schmuck
I mean you know deep down these movies
are very good that's for him to know and
for you to review all right but I'm
gonna get to the bottom of this sniff by
Bardo Mimi and diver yes yes you I don't
think that technically makes that that's
the matrix a nutshell now go so after
the Smiths tried to destroy Tom Tom
apparently seems invulnerable again not
quite explained he could still bleed and
die in the other two movies as Smith
starts to question what the fuck he's
even doing there we're laying right
there like that
I stand here right here I'm supposed to
say is something I think a weaving just
got drunk and is trying to remember what
he was supposed to do in the script I
just say God I don't care how smashed
I'm coming across nobody's gonna be in
the theater to watch it anyway but Tom
finally lets him win and take over his
body is it over
shouldn't I know aren't you me and me
you and why am i such a crying pussy all
of a sudden what a goofy laugh help ah
ha ha ha but Tom spirit results in
metaphorical overload as the two
entities balance each other out
destroying one another actually in all
fairness a pretty clever idea for a
resolution but Jesus do we have to sit
through so much of what we've already
seen before
goodness scene just be summed up in Leo
you have Smith malware to delete it
press whoa for yes or bocas for no you
have selected whoa
it'll result in all my boring
characteristics being permanently
deleted you have selected whoa
37 times arsh this of course results in
the death of Tom in the real world
Oh
well that's going on
it looks like Zion is finally safe
thanks random boy with no authority who
were just gonna choose to believe for
some reason so everything goes back to
normal and the machines agree to free
anyone who wakes up from the matrix in
the future mr. critic and now it seems
there's no purpose to your insistence no
blood
wait a minute I know what you guys are
you're you're the strangers from Dark
City very clever
yes but why we were so pissed off that I
movie bombed earning only the slightest
of a cult following we knew we had to
retell our story to a more popular
market we dumbed it down for a broader
demographic of course a world controlled
by emotionless entities a lead who adapt
to his powers a dark environment ruled
by human imposters secretly observing
them hell didn't even ends with two
people flying around destroying a city
but it wasn't enough so we replaced
character development with gunfights
vague undertones with obvious symbolism
and classic film noir with sexy people
intact Elvis it was a big hit but
something went wrong
the audience is caught on to our
gimmicks and grew tired of the sequels
but you mister out Jenna you can say how
bad it is and grow the audience's
curiosity back no no you know as well as
I do more attention should be brought to
think their time was not what's just
popular for the moment we've tried it
before we dare not try it again
nor will you
Chester I told you I don't do anything
beyond that makes much more sense you're
probably wondering why I keep appearing
in all your memories is because they
have inserted me something we didn't
force you see I have been spinning The
Strangers for some time really to
destroy them
by using their very own power known as
ruining the ability to ruin a perfectly
good idea with but you turn to critic
all you have to do is finish the review
but you must act now
The Matrix films are silly but harmless
what in the grand scheme of things there
are some good ideas Neath visuals and
clever analogies there's much smarter
ones out there but at the same time this
did at least get the ball rolling for
people to say hey action films can make
you think and can push the envelope of
what was visually possible before it
action films didn't have to look like
anything that's special
just people shooting guns jumping
through explosions stuff like that but
now every film has to have a visual
style if it's going to be recognized at
all in today's media this means so many
more options for creative imagery and
inventive imagination and let's give
credit where credit's due this is most
likely because of the matrix even it's
not the best it did change a whole lot
and deserves to be acknowledged for that
now let's be honest every film even the
sequels has something good in it so on
the whole while I personally don't enjoy
them they did do more good than maybe I
realized to begin with and none of them
not even the last one are really
god-awful know you must hate them you
must hate them
much the people have to see them no I
don't I think it's time to use some of
this ruining power to get things back to
normal no more of a color green
a Spanish dear
and no more snowman
ah much better
I'm dying
mr. Alger critic we research so many
popular stories so many timeless
philosophies so many important founding
words
why couldn't we make our characters more
human you want to know what makes a
character human well you're not gonna
find it in this what looking in the
wrong place
hey Malcolm hey Tamara what a beautiful
colorful day sure is
hey you guys are slowly why is that
weird
I don't know just haven't seen in a
while okay hey you guys gonna go hang
out at the mall why so instead for hours
discussing our purpose or role in life
no just hang out and talk well I guess
yes I would
I spy with my little eye something
beginning with M me dear
cookies need love like everything does